tous les matins sur matinale sur rtl à
l'usaf 25 et on trouve effectivement le
best-of le best-of dans ce cd voilà
alors tout le monde y passe à nantes
c'est là et in thomas c'est mon choix
oui ça vous a plu c'est mon choix oui
j'aime bien quand vous critiquez les
émissions de mes concurrents laurent
boyer qui a été très gentil avec vous
lors encore vous êtes arrivé à paris il
a été vachement gentil et malgré tout
fait une interview de garou par laurent
boyer qui était fait semblant mais il
il le prend bien le remplir plus on se
connaît oui il ya beaucoup de gens qui
le prennent bien contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait penser oui parce que je
ne fais pas avec méchanceté que c'est ça
oui il ya la vie de bernadette soubirous
par bellemare grand rayonnement et loana
il a beaucoup inspiré au silo à grain
d'sel la dent dure a quand même parce
que j'étais pour le loft non que je le
dis d'autant plus avant ou d'un we found
love
ah oui oui parce que j'ai comme la
chanson de ferrer j'aime bien ma soir
pour voir passer les cons donc là je les
avais forcément comment soir
ça montre aussi toute une génération qui
a été élevée aux radios libres à peu
près trois mois son vocabulaire donc
c'est toujours bien alors justement
mathilde le signe du partout dans la
presse en ce moment oui qu elle et les
gentils ouais et que chaque fois qu'elle
a dit du mal
voilà le mal des [ __ ] des arabes
dumas de me sophie marceau l'a dit mais
moi je suis une fille vachement sympa
c'est laurent gerra qui m'a influencé ou
donc il faut dire à notre ami de il y
souligne les versions méfier quand même
non non non je vais de l'influx ans
comme ça si on l'aidera dans sa housse
joue pas longtemps avec une balle qui
rebondit pas donc je réponds pas à ce
genre de srec
mais je vous pose la question c'est
normal c'est normal ça avec vous allez
me la poser c'est mon travail mais fait
quand viendra karen mulder
je peux vous en parler nous ont trahis
vous voulez que je vous en parle oui ben
est arrivé sur ce plateau et pour
témoigner sur un certain nombre de
choses et elle était dans un état
psychologique très perturbé qui a fait
qu' on ne veut pas diffuser son
interview voilà sinon on l'aurait fait
oui voila merci mais je réponds pas
laurent gerra le cd best of elections
matinale à 8h30 sur rtl
quand gérard vous ne serez pas étonné
que je vous fasse une interview nul non
tirées on approche pendant le petit gars
est ce que vous préférez
hitler staline ben laden ou mao ont des
causes que vous vous demandez pas ni
aucun des quatre bas il ya des gens qui
disent tallinn par exemple on béru ouais
voilà le robert non non non non aucun
des quatre noms parce qu'en plus j'ai vu
j'ai vu la lada tchad staline à sotchi
ouais et il y avait la guide était
vraiment terrorisé quand elle a vu les
espèces de statues de staline falloir la
production de ces dictateurs on peut pas
aimer les dictateurs un peu sophie
marceau dire ça c'est des dictateurs on
peut pas attention c'est sophie marceau
qui est une grande actrice comme dit
mathilde seigner bien vous devez partir
de 3 ans n'ont jamais sauce spatiale oui
trois ans ce spécial préféré partir avec
laure sinclair qui va nous rejoindre
tout à perdre et à anne sinclair ou bob
sinclair leur sinclair lorsque l arrêter
le porno en même temps je vous le dis
bonjour au scrabble
à qui accorder vous le plus de
circonstance et c'est à tomber sur
mauvais du pauvre acquis accordez-vous
le plus de circonstances atténuantes it
est un vieux qui se tape des petites ou
un jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles un
jeune qui table sur des vieilles juge
pas moins bas ni l'un ni l'autre mais
bon si j'allais mais qu'au-delà de 50
ans ils disent aux vieux qui se tape des
deux petites kahn n'est pas encore dans
celle ça dépend ce que ce qui est petit
ce débat majeur ou pas avec ce sont
maintenant ça peut être que des majeures
avec la loi qui est passé dans un majeur
ou oui oui provient pas des majeurs de
15 ans bien sûr excitante aussi le mot
le plus con l'amour et vous vous y
connaissez
est-ce que c'est merci encore
ou oui oui oui parce que ça rappelle
l'enfance a à peine les looks à la grace
est cotée en bourse
je pose pas la question son aide non non
non cette question est encore plus que
tout accepteriez-vous d'échanger une
paralysie générale contre la faim de la
famine dans l'afrique subsaharienne
or la vache à dieu c'est vrai je peux
pas répondre là que vous n'êtes pas
gentil finalement moi mais je suis
méchant demandé à mathilde seigner
c'est nous qui connaissions alors à qui
empruntent auriez vous le plus
volontiers son cerveau pour une grèce
mais dit pologne non non j'ai du cerveau
j'aime beaucoup le jeu n'en veut pas
j'aime beaucoup la manne alors à qui
empruntent feriez-vous son cerveau pour
une greffe à valéry giscard d'estaing
nicolas sarkozy mme jacques chirac je
suis toujours dit que quelques hommes
politiques soient même si je m'en moque
arrivé à ce niveau là c'était quand même
que des mecs étaient intelligents mais
de là à les leur chercher le cerveau ne
sache pas chirac
pourquoi j'irais du président n'aurait
pu parce qu'ils voient des coûts et donc
ce sera vous laver les cheveux tous les
combien pourquoi ça se voit qu'ils sont
sales non c'est la question de contrôle
intervenu quand ingrate
ouais si vous deviez interdire un truc à
la télé ça serait la pub ou le porno
pour la pub
élection matinale
décor de l'émission
le soleil
et il ya plein de trucs qu'il faudra
interdire le jour du seigneur par
exemple pourquoi parce que pourquoi je
paye une redevance pourra voir le jour
du seigneur
mais ces corses et anticlérical y en a
plus des gens qui sont ici chez ricoh
aujourd'hui oui c'est un pourquoi sur
mac l'as bompas que me soupçonne même
pas l'église l'église catholique
maintenant on n'a plus ce pouvoir là
c'est sert à rien de lui taper dessus en
tire pas sur les ambulances
ah bon ouais bah alors on enlève le jour
du seigneur bon et l'émission musulmane
et l'émission juive aussi oui oui on
toutes les émissions religieuses non non
au programme un an
oui oui oui oui oui oui vous êtes athée
anticlérical ou est contre le mariage
oui toujours oui même maintenant
j'ai toujours contre le mariage tout et
c'est bien le mariage regardez vous
allez vous marier non ah mais non je me
suis jamais mariée mais pas de mari non
plus ah non c'est pas dans le programme
je vous laisser filer parce que vous
avez rendez vous avec avec l'homme avec
qui vous n'allez pas vous marier
voilà vous laisse partir merci en tous
les cas des devenu je sais que c'est
rare